land unter in willofs an georges rund 16
kilometer vom zentrum der französischen
hauptstadt paris entfernt
starke regenfälle haben die nahegelegene
und ihre nebenflüsse stark anschwellen
lassen
in der stadt mit rund 30.000 einwohnern
herrschte ausnahmezustand
viele keller und erdgeschosse sind mit
wasser vollgelaufen viele einwohner
können nicht mehr in ihre häuser gehen
in einigen vorgärten soll anderthalb
meter wasser stehen die rettungskräfte
sind mit booten im einsatz um die
betroffenen bürger in sicherheit zu
bringen
auch lastwagen der armee sollen hier zum
einsatz kommen dieser mann ist besorgt
wenn das noch weiter steigt dann bin ich
am ende eigentlich bin ich schon seit
zwei tagen am limit
er steigt weiter nur noch einen
zentimeter und ich werde komplett
überflutet
es hört sich nicht viel an aber dieser
eine zentimeter konnte entscheidung sein
es ist ein problem 670 erwartung auch in
paris steigt der pegel der sun weiter
am samstag erwarten die experten neue
höchststände
der busverkehr wurde eingestellt u bahn
stationen und mehrere museen haben
vorsorglich geschlossen die
eisenbahngesellschaft sncf schloss
mehrere innenstadt station hausboot
besitzer mussten ihre schiffe verlassen
wie sah man glaubt dass sich die
menschen in paris an solche zustände
gewöhnen müssen
die regel sagt ries ich denke das
schlechte wetter wird nicht heute oder
morgen aufhören
es ist für eine längere zeit wir hören
sehr viel über die globale erwärmung und
klimakatastrophen es wird lange dauern
sich darum zu kümmern
eine entspannung ist erst einmal nicht
in sicht der nationale wetterdienst hat
für 19 departement die warnstufe orange
ausgerufen das ist die zweithöchste
warnstufe
die bevölkerung wurde aufgerufen
unnötige reisen zu vermeiden und
vorsichtig zu sein